carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a este programa
especial carrusel de las artes desde el
impactante alfombra roja de cannes
edición número 74 de este famoso
festival que se hizo tras la pandemia
del cómic pero esto no afectó el desfile
de estrellas aquí en cannes a compañía
[Música]
les hablaremos de la película que ganó
la palma de oro este año y de los
principales galardones que se entregaron
en el festival de cannes conversaremos
con apichatpong weerasethakul a el
director tailandés estuvo en la
competencia con memoria una cinta
filmada en colombia en forma de singular
aventura sensorial y también en nuestro
programa la directora mexicano
salvadoreña tatiana hueso autora de una
cinta sensible y dura sobre la condición
de las niñas en mexico
[Música]
el festival de cannes fue durante 12
días una luminosa fiesta del séptimo
arte mundial 24 cintas aspiraban a la
palma de oro el máximo galardón de este
certamen que se entregó como extradición
en una elegante velada aquí en el
palacio de los festivales melissa barra
nos comentan los principales premios de
esta edición luces cámara acción
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sin sorpresas la película titán de la
francesa liu liu kun no se alzó con la
palma de oro del festival de cannes 28
años después de jane campion yoko ono se
convirtió en la segunda mujer en recibir
la máxima recompensa de este certamen
[Música]
estas cintas que causó un electroshock
en la juanetes una mezcla de violencia
horror sexo y fantasía una apuesta
resueltamente monstruosa que asumió su
autora julia y con los ojos aún portando
en el creo que es importante seleccionar
películas de género en los festivales
como cannes porque es así que podremos
educar al público a aceptar propuestas
cinematográficas más diversas
y tan cuenta la historia de álex ya una
chica a la que le implantan una placa de
titanio en la cabeza veinte años después
álex ya cambia de identidad y se
convierte en un serial killers que se
cruza en su camino con un jefe de los
bomberos interpretado por el veterano
actor francés
vih
y el actual marco del reparto lo cual
fue formidable esta juventud me enseñó
muchas cosas formas modernas de hablar
de hacer cine ellos aprendieron mucho de
mí pero yo también aprendí muchas cosas
de julia y de su manera de concebir el
cine soy notación valiosísima con esta
palma de ahora una directora joven y
radical el festival de cannes y su
presidente del jurado este año spike lee
enviaron un mensaje contundente a una
industria donde las mujeres todavía
siguen siendo minoritarias el gran
premio se atribuyó a dos películas un
héroe de asghar farhadi y compartimento
número 6 del finlandés juho kuosmanen
dos jóvenes desconocidos se apoderaron
de los premios de interpretación y la
sueca reina terrain sube por yulia en 12
capítulos y el estadounidense caleb
landry jones por su increíble rol de
nitram un marginal atraído por la
pirotecnia y las armas de fuego
página
[Música]
[Aplausos]
entre las 24 cintas en la competencia
este año estuvo memoria del tailandés
apichatpong weerasethakul la única
película filmada en américa latina'
hablada parcialmente en español y
protagonizada por tilda swinton su
director nos comentó que fue filmar allí
en colombia
[Música]
active plans que en colombia tiene
paisajes muy dinámicos todo cambia con
mucha rapidez como el clima la tierra
tiembla hay terremotos y deslizamientos
como si los elementos entraran en
comunicación con nosotros y a mí me
gusta negociar con ellos eso es light es
de esta única obsesión es like
rumbo a memoria es una aventura
sensorial que explora el unir ismo y lo
sobrenatural la historia de una escocesa
que escucha detonaciones que no la dejan
dormir y la llevan a recorrer el país en
busca de una explicación
memoria de apichatpong weerasethakul
compartió el premio del jurado con la
rodilla de del israelí nadav lapid en su
estreno mundial en cannes el director
tailandés junto con su elenco
desplegaron una bandera ss colombia en
apoyo al pueblo colombiano
[Música]
el festival de cine de cannes nos
permitió conocer este año a la directora
mexicano salvadoreña tatiana hueso quien
estuvo en selección oficial una cierta
mirada con su película noche de fuego
[Música]
y no se mueva r - es una alegría
tremenda estar aquí me siento muy
privilegiada y muy muy feliz muy
orgullosa de haber llegado hasta aquí
con con esta primera película de ficción
este siento que es un primer paso muy
fuerte para el camino de esta película
fue una sorpresa la noticia la verdad y
en un momento muy particular además del
mundo de la vida no este después de un
año tan tan duro para para todos es algo
increíble hermoso tatiana y esta
película noche de fuego cuenta la
historia está ambientada en una aldea de
montaña y sigue a tres niñas que crecen
que se vuelven adolescentes pero que
viven en el peligro de ser robadas
secuestradas o asesinadas cuéntanos cómo
llegaste a esta historia que te llevó a
llevarla al cine si en el momento que
llegó a mis manos esta historia yo
estaba sumergida en una investigación
en escuelas rurales indagando sobre lo
que significa crecer estaba sumergida en
el único en el universo de la infancia
adolescencia en esas estaba cuando
nicolás celis el productor de la
película y productor de mis dos
anteriores películas me propuso leer un
libro éste de jennifer clement que en
español se llama lady be es una novela
muy adrenalínica la devoré rápidamente
en tres días me enamoré de la niña
protagonista quien en la película noche
de fuego se llama anna y me pareció
sumamente interesante el contexto en el
que crece esta niña en un contexto
violento enmarcado por la siembra de
amapola había una investigación
periodística importante sobre el mundo
de la amapola en méxico específicamente
en la montaña de guerrero cerca de
acapulco guerrero este que es en donde
se desarrolla la historia en el libro no
entonces fue fue una enorme inspiración
y un punto de partida para poder hacer
la adaptación y si le pedí poder
aproximarme a esta historia desde mi
búsqueda
y desde mi propia mirada sobre la
violencia en méxico y así le entregué a
esta película si nació
anoche se metieron una casa se llevaron
una muchacha
aunque tres los labios pintados
sabemos que ha sido un año difícil
ustedes son las mamás de mis alumnos y
me gustaría que me dijeran que estaban
sobre lo que pasó
yo creo que nos pasó cuando una de
nosotras tres de repente se vaya
y ahora estas niñas que están en esta
aldea son tres y que las vemos crecer
siempre sentimos el peligro que acecha
los grupos que pasan los rumores pero no
es una película violenta tampoco tú no
muestras la violencia pero creas ese es
impacto no es a esa espera por algo que
va a pasar
si las niñas crecen en un contexto
violento
hay un monstruo latente que está allí
que permea su mundo que permea su
realidad pero que no vemos es es muy
dura la realidad que hay en méxico desde
hace muchos años no la violencia que ha
marcado y ha definido la vida de tantas
familias que están buscando a sus hijas
desaparecidas a sus hijos este no es la
primera vez que le entró a estos temas
de violencia no como te decía antes la
violencia ha marcado a méxico en los
últimos años hay miles de familias
buscando a sus hijos desaparecidos para
mí era muy importante
huir alejarme de la representación
gráfica de esta violencia que nos ha
contaminado tanto la mirada y el alma
que nos ha hecho perder la dimensión de
la tragedia en donde todos se vuelven
estadistas estadísticas y números
siento que esta es una película que
tiene este contexto que tiene este
monstruo latente pero que no es una
película más del narcotráfico ni de
violencia no siento que la mirada está
puesta en la construcción de unos
personajes femeninos complejos
entrañables con quiénes caminar de la
mano
y sé como que me propuse no juzgar a mis
personajes no encasillar los no
llenarlas de clichés no yo estoy muy
cansada y muy aburrida de ver a la mujer
representada en las películas por lo
menos en muchas mexicanas está trazada
con dos pinceladas muy aburridas muy
burdas de lo que no somos porque somos
seres muy complejos no entonces son
personajes llenos de claroscuros también
me propuse mucho huir de la
victimización no son mujeres que son
niñas semilla cuando yo la escribía está
el guión decías ellas son niñas semillas
van a ser mujeres que van a poder
incidir en su realidad son niñas que
adquieren un pensamiento crítico en las
escuelas rurales de su comunidad son
niñas que cuestionan a sus mamás son
niñas que cuestionan el mundo donde
viven y para mí era muy importante poder
generar este tipo de personajes
femeninos reales no como somos las
mujeres en la vida real y espero que la
película llegue al público y toque y
pueda
la gente de este festival que además es
un público muy exquisito muy crítico y
muy sabio no digamos este pues que puede
entrar en el viaje de estas pequeñas y
sentir sentir lo que sucede en el mundo
de ellas gracias tatiana de hueso y
muchas gracias
no sé cómo le vas a hacer pero tienes
que mandar a traerla
[Música]
es cómete
tenemos por la niña madre
tenemos que de aquí está su mención
especial mención noche del juego
noche de fuego de tatiana huezo recibió
una mención especial del jurado de la
sección una cierta mirada en caracas
[Música]
y aquí ponemos punto final este programa
especial que les presentamos desde la
alfombra roja del festival de cine de
cannes muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta aventura
cinematográfica y hasta la próxima
agua
[Música]